i want to see a deeper investigation
into whether or not these shootings and
other similar crimes are
racially motivated it looks racially
motivated to me
that's senator tammy duckworth appearing
on sunday's
on sunday on cbs's face the nation
drawing a different assessment
than fbi director christopher wray last
week rey
said the deadly atlanta area shootings
that killed eight people
six of asian descent did not
seem to be linked to race but over the
weekend there were anti-hate rallies and
vigils from coast-to-coast showing
support and solidarity for the
asian-american community
in san francisco sidewalks were painted
remembering the names of those killed
in san jose thousands marched with signs
saying unite against
racism in new york there were peaceful
demonstrations on saturday and sunday
in atlanta demonstrators met at liberty
plaza across the street
from the georgia state capitol holding
signs saying
hate is a virus and in our nation's
capital
activists also took to the street with
signs like this
that said proud to be asian american
and joining us now is the co-host of the
real jeannie may
her family immigrated from vietnam i am
so happy
to have you on the show tonight um to
talk to you about this
really important issue everyone i think
is reeling after last week's violence
because in a lot of ways
it felt foreseeable um and
and almost like it was coming because of
all the other incidents we'd seen
how have you been processing everything
zerlina you hit the nail on the head i
have been
angry and very heartbroken i feel like
america had all the signs that they
needed to prevent this and when i say
they i mean we
one year ago the asian american
community begged please
please stop the rhetoric our former
president called this disease the kung
flu and china virus and these words
directed anger and resentment towards us
and we have to know that words become
actions
speech that conjures hate will lead to
violence
and last week a massacre so we had
red flags for over a year it was open
season on asian americans
and i feel that america has a big
problem i mean you can see it through
history
we saw it in 2020 2020 was the result of
our black brothers and sisters
feeling oppressed for centuries and they
still are
so america needs to know that when
people ask for help when they beg for
help believe them
absolutely believe them and in terms of
using your platform to speak out i think
it's really important
that in this particular moment so many
um asian americans
in the creative space in pop culture um
you're the host one of the co-hosts of
the real are using their platforms to
really
talk about this issue authentically and
honestly
um speak to some of the conversations
you've been having
while you're using your platform to
speak out because as you said you know
this shooting was
after asian americans had been saying
begging
stop using these racist terms for a
coronavirus because
it is directly linked to violence being
committed in real life
absolutely i have to speak out on this
because i don't want this to happen to
another ethnic group who is it going to
be next
i feel that our country has
so much embedded racism and now we have
so much tension in turmoil because of
this pandemic and everybody's
pent it up and just enraged and confused
and and for every reason they need to be
you know our
our households are are um either
suffering because of weather or because
of lack of being able to make some
income or
being able to feel protected so at the
end of the day we only have one another
and we have to band together and
i want to speak out on this as loudly
and as
efficiently as i can because i would
hate to see another ethnic group be
targeted
absolutely i feel i feel the same way
ever since i was a little kid my mom
always used to say
you know you were the person that like
saw somebody being bullied
and took it personally on their behalf
like i was mad
about somebody else being bullied
because i wouldn't want it to happen to
me and i wouldn't want someone to stand
up
for me if it were if it were happening
to me in terms of
um some of the stereotypes associated
with asian women i think
you know it's frustrating to hear people
in law enforcement come out and say
it's not about race um because of his
cited
alleged addiction to sex um but
it is about race it's also about gender
because they intersect
especially in this case and so speak to
some of the stereotypes of asian women
that may have contributed to the events
we saw last week
absolutely um damaging stereotypes of
asian women started back
hundreds of years ago even before the
chinese exclusion act of 1882 which
banned
chinese immigrants from becoming u.s
citizens the u.s had passed the page act
of 1875 which ultimately banned
the importation of asian women because
they were feared to be engaging in
prostitution in the country whether they
were
or were not by the way and all to say it
is so dangerous to fetishize women
because
that means you see us as objects and
this atlanta shooter made it
super clear when he said that the spas
were a temptation he wanted to eliminate
instead of seeing delanayan as a wife
who was on a couple's massage date with
her husband
balji tan as an immigrant business owner
who was
one day shy of her 50th birthday dao
yufeng as a hard-working employee
paul andre michaels as a combat veteran
who was doing maintenance work for the
spa to stay afloat
pyeongchang grant as a school teacher
and a single mother to two sons
tsuncha kim who was a 69 year old
grandmother for her family who worked
two to three jobs to provide
tsunchang park as a 74 year old elder
yang a yu
who was recently laid off because of the
pandemic and was
actually excited to come back to work at
the spa again this shooter who'd
viewed these lives as objects
it's so important to say their names and
to understand that
they all had families they all had
dreams they all had goals
they were all fully human um in terms of
the posit some positive stereotypes i
want to pivot
um to some of the other stereotypes
associated with asian people
i i've talked to my friends who are in
the api community of all backgrounds
about the model minority myth and how
it's effectively used
often to divide black people from asian
people from
latinx people um and and instead of
allowing us to all come together to
fight back against discrimination that's
happening to us
absolutely there is nothing positive
about the model minority myth it's not
something we asked upon us it's not
something we wanted
it was actually created in 1966 by
sociologist
william peterson he coined the term to
describe asians as the most successful
minority group
and this caused an immediate comparison
between asian people
and all other people of color which
pitted us against each other
like i'm going to give you an example
imagine you've got two kids
right where one child is constantly
revered by his parent
and the other is always being denigrated
rather than bonding
these two kids inevitably will grow to
be highly competitive
possibly even resentful of one another
and instead of uniting over painful
oppression
now minorities judge and distrust one
another instead of being allies we're
enemies of one another
so another major cornerstone of asians
is that the model minority myth
we're commended for being compliant and
a silent group that's part of what model
minority stood for
so we stay silent and authorities and
media ignore us
and the lesson is that we learn as an
asian community that we now have to
unlearn this ingrained habit of staying
quiet
and the rest of the world needs to wake
up and acknowledge that we exist
yeah it's it's so interesting to talk
about
how even a positive stereotype can have
negative
consequences in in small ways every
single day i think everybody
at home um you know can do their part
there are ways in which we can
take small steps to check our own biases
to check our own privilege
how do you recommend people do that well
the first thing you can do
immediately is if you want to support
the families
the communities and the grassroot
organizations that are working so hard
to build back these communities that
have been targeted then you can go to
gofundme
aapi so gofundme aapi
and these are vetted out organizations
that go directly to these victims and
these organizations
and the second one is i want to share a
tweet from eva duvernay
um an amazing strong black woman who was
standing in solidarity with us
and she tweeted to examine stereotypes
you hold about asian people
work to dismantle that within yourself
raise your voice
anywhere that anti-asian sentiment is
present present
and normalize calling it out and i
remind our asian brothers and sisters to
do the same
for our black brothers and sisters who
we know all too well i've suffered for
this for way too
long it's so important jeanne mai thank
you so much for being here tonight
um it was really important conversation
and i want to i hope you're safe and
that you survived the pandemic because
we just have to get through this moment
to get to the next one which is i'm sure
going to be better
it's going to be better that's what i
believe we always have to push through
please stay safe
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching